richest 20 billionaires own the same
wealth
as 50 of world's population indy 100
says the prototype sneakers are a
relic okay wait that's a difference on
tuesday it starts with on tuesday the
popular business on tuesday the popular
business magazine released its annual
list of worlds wealthiest individuals
and interval
inadvertently shed light on the vast
economic inequalities worldwide one
eye-catching statistic stood out
the combined wealth of just 20 of the
world's
top 20 billionaires feature 2.1 trillion
dollars is greater than the wealth owned
by the bottom 50 percent of the world
population
as uh for the top one percent of
americans have combined net worth of
35.2 trillion dollars that's comparable
to just over 30.4
percent of all household wealth in u.s
according to the data
from federal reserve global billionaire
wealth has skyrocketed at an
unprecedented rate since 1989 in
addition the pandemic
has somehow allowed american
billionaires to grow remarkably richer
such as elon musk who became the world's
fifth billionaire
fifth centa billionaire that's 100
billion plus august of 2020 crossing
100 billion dollar benchmark what are
your thoughts on this well tell us
um i want to i want to set up my friend
john stossel here my new friend and john
stossel actually
he has his own youtube channel it's
called stosseltv
if i'm if i'm correct awesome usually
clips
under 10 minutes on hard hitting topics
and john stossel did
an entire episode on wealth inequality
did you not
i've done central i've done several he
said but one is pretty poignant and he
said
here's some of the stats he said the
worldwide population over the last 40
years a billion people have
risen out of poverty here in america the
richest americans have
increased their wealth by 200 percent uh
where the poorest americans have
increased their wealth by 32 percent
so i'm gonna make a point and then i'm
gonna i'm gonna hand this over to you so
i think the
the problem is number one let's just
applaud that wealth inequality
well that the a billion people have
gotten out of poverty i think that's a
huge headline that
gets sort of pushed to the side because
people want to focus on the headlines
you know in the news world they say
don't bury the lead
the lead is 20 billionaires are richer
than 50 percent of the world
that's ridiculous what they won't say is
well the world in itself the poorest of
the poor are getting richer so the rich
are getting richer
but the poor aren't necessarily getting
poor
is that right though we hear that the
rich got richer and the poor got
poorer it's [ __ ] the poor got
30 over 40 years richer too
and the middle class is disappearing but
more of them are moving into the
higher classes it's just the media is
horrible at making everything seem worse
than it is
and they do relate the billionaires it's
a tournament
world the free market world and the
freakonomics guys had a chapter on why
the crack dealer is living with his
mother still
but at the top of the chain of the crack
dealers there was a very rich guy and
the average
soldier wasn't making much money but
presumably he was taking that risk
to do this illegal thing because he was
making a little more
than he would have otherwise and in
america now we're acting as if
it's a bad thing if somebody gets filthy
rich
while other people only get a little
richer but that's what's going to happen
when people are free
and it's the only system that allows
people to get richer
because for most of history for
thousands and thousands of years
everybody was poor it was only in the
last
200 300 years that gdp has
shot up and not 1 billion but many
billions
have been lifted out of poverty and
poverty as the u.n defines it is
living on a buck or two a day it's it's
stoop labor it's very awful and the same
system that makes
bezos absurdly rich
has a lot has trickled down if that's
the terrible word
to those people and i'm not even
counting how much their lives are better
off
because apple invented stuff like this
iphones and
that makes a poor person's life richer
of course and i think
income tends to be equal when everybody
is poor
so i know you have very strong feelings
about this pat you've talked to you've
done episodes about this yeah
what are your thoughts i mean it's
listen it's very basic for me kai can
you pull up on uh on the big screen
compound interest rule of 72
and show in uh what happens if
yeah just put compound interest compound
interest
rule of 72 you know what matter of fact
go to yeah type that let's see what
comes up examples i'm just curious here
go to images let's see what comes up on
their images
you know the chart that shows if you
make an investment in different uh
okay go to the first one rule of 72. go
to the first one let's see how blurry it
is it's a little too blur okay there you
go
okay so if you look at that here's what
you'll notice
if the average person takes ten thousand
dollars and they get one and a half
percent
interest rate okay you put that at a
rule of 72
it's gonna take roughly uh what one uh
uh
so two would be thirty seconds forty
eight years for the ten thousand dollars
to double to twenty thousand dollars
at three percent that same person same
amount of money they put in three
percent say fixed annuity or
a a t bill maybe not today's t bill but
let's just say something you put it in
that pays you three percent
that's going to be forty thousand
dollars forty eight years later the six
percent is going to have 160 000
the 12 is going to have 2.56 million
dollars look at the difference between
six and 12 percent atom
look at six look at 12. at six you're
gonna have 160 000
48 years later at 12 you're gonna have
2.56 million dollars
i asked john i said john how come you're
not moving to florida
john says he loves delray he's about to
go you're going to you're going to play
you're going to play a very very high
high quality
competitive volleyball today right beach
volleyball and
low quality competitive only plays with
the girls
tells me he's going to be competing he's
a very smart man he says i'll be the guy
the one guy i'll be setting the girls up
i'm the bumper yeah and the girls will
be the spikers so i asked i said so how
come you're not moving to florida
at this phase you know it's just not
something that's a you know at
you know something that's a big deal to
want to move over why
because he's probably had compound
interest on his side over the last 10 20
30 40 years
so most of america most of the world
doesn't put their money to work for them
most of the world
if you look at the most basic simple
this is not saying
10 000 a year this isn't saying 10 000
a month this is saying ten thousand
dollars you
leave it you set it there you don't
touch it for 48 years
you got 2.56 million dollars let's just
say you put that in a fund like
investment company of act a company act
of america that say
american funds they started i think in
1934
and their average return they talk about
over you know lifespan is 12 plus
percent
say it's 12 percent say it's 10 you got
more money so when we're talking about
you know the richest 20 billionaires are
worth more than the bottom 50
yeah the richest billionaires have their
equity working for them they typically
own a piece of a company they typically
have compound interest on their side
and unfortunately the bottom 50 percent
of the world is not educated on how
money works why are they i don't
know you know all these people all our
politicians all the politicians in new
york who
yesterday aoc came out and imposing the
fact that we got to make a bigger
aggressive push on climate change and
they're trying to push joe biden because
joe biden the other day flipped he kind
of apologized a little bit and they
changed their
approach because they were worried that
aoc and those guys were going to come
after them
if aoc if elizabeth warren if these
folks are
so worried about the poor of america
why don't you educate them about the
basics of how money works why don't you
try to get them out of being poor why
keep them there
they don't know who don't who they don't
know how much
he doesn't understand certainly i i
wouldn't disagree with but elizabeth
warren does she's written a book on this
she's not she understands it but the
point is the point is do they
really want them to stop being poor do
you really want them to stop being poor
that opens up another can of worms yeah
what do they really want do they want to
keep them in that poor mentality and
i don't know rail against the road oh
come on that's too paranoid you're
being crazy here they want to help
people too
these stupid leftists you think so yeah
yeah you think they do what sweet uh
sentimental
guy you are jealous i think they are
misguided but i think they really want
to help
okay i think i think you're worried
about going back to new york and you
want to
you want to make sure they let you back
in because you want to go see your wife
i i can respect that
well back to the initial point is i
think the stat is
fifty-five percent of americans yeah in
america here i get that we have an
international we got tequila there just
so yeah
3 500 that tequila is coming up and
john's eye in it as well go ahead you're
on that
kill like me shout out to the rock but
anyway my point is 55
of americans uh are invested in the
stock market yeah basically flip a coin
whether you're invested in the stock
market or not
i know that john has obviously done very
well in the stock market as of you and i
had to learn the hard way of like all
right what the hell is this but i
actually just did an episode
on valuetainment economics about
investing and i said compound interest
is your homie he's your amigo he's your
compadre right
and if you're not investing in the stock
market or bitcoin and what have you
even real estate for that matter you're
not gonna get the
magical effect of compound interest and
i think einstein once said that compound
interest is the eighth wonder of the
world
those who understand it earn it those
who don't you know do not get it so
um but back to the initial point about
the billionaire and the mill you know so
something that that
we've all learned this past year is the
k-shaped economy the rich are getting
richer and the poor getting poorer
which john so pointlessly pointed out
that they're actually not getting poor
they're just not getting as rich
but i think at the end of the day it
comes down to emotion and the emotion is
sort of the crab mentality you're
familiar with the crab mentality that if
you have a bucket of crabs
and one tries to get its way out one
will pull its way down
so i don't think people are upset with
like the
the bezos of the world or the must of
the world the entrepreneurs the guys
building businesses i think what they're
upset about for a lack of a better word
are the
freaking douchebags with the four yachts
and the seven mansions what are you
talking
you you you you live in the i know i
live in the capital of douchebags i do
i do and believe me those guys i go in
there you're not going to go on the next
job
going on there yet i'm good but i'm just
saying this guy
he was just on a yacht last night i was
i was but
the problem is people that don't get
those invites on the yacht are like
those guys so there's the hater
mentality i'm saying that people are
haters i see
do you not think that people are haters
especially the rich at the end of the
day yeah and if the guy in the yacht
cheated to get there then i hate him
okay like the madoffs of the world hello
yeah
ponzi schemers they they deserve to be
held accountable so
but but your question is your question
is the 20 billionaires being
where they are the top 20 having more
than 50 percent of world population
does that bother you are you okay with
that yeah i mean look at the who are the
top 20 billionaires elon musk
jeff bezos by the way 25
of people like uh zug 75 do not like
zuck
by the way uh buffett uh
who's the guy lvmh
uh i think this is a compound interest
issue and it's an education issue it's
that simple listen when i was
growing up in a family when my dad was
working at a 99 center my parents got a
divorce and i'm living in a
you know a one-bedroom place where my
mom and my sister off of doran
yeah we had no money we had no clue what
the hell we were doing no one in my
family ever owned an insurance policy a
401 i've never
lived in a house before so guess how
much compound interest we had
eventually the money my dad my grandpa
gave my mom eventually ran out and when
she ran out of money guess what she
did she went straight back to iran is
what she did because we didn't know how
money worked
and when money ran ran out she went back
to iran and i joined the army
i had no clue how money work then i went
into the army i got out i met a girl
jean vieire she worked at morgan stanley
dean with her she told me
you ought to get into financial services
i said i have no clue what morgan
stanley dean witter is
21. long story short i get hired when i
get hired and i learn out i got my
series 7
then i sat there and i said this makes a
lot of sense why don't more people know
about
the basics of money not even the
technical
how a t-bond works versus a you know
variable annuity all
basic stuff that people don't even know
about how money works so
maybe invest a little bit more into
education about money if we actually
want to get people to be out of it
educate them about how money works
get people to be encouraged to go into
compound interest have your money
working for you
and see what happens to your long term
may not be a bad idea
to go read i bet these 20 billionaires
they probably have a book out there
about how they did it
why don't you go read that book so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]